- Revire
un mandat d'arrêt a été émis
contre l'ancien procureur
général du pays Jesus Murillo.
Il est accusé de disparition
fo
d'entrave à la justice,
pour la disparition en 2014
de 43 étudiants.
Cette arrestation survient
au lendemain de la publication
d'enquête responsable
du dossier. Elle quafifie
cette affaire de crime d'État,
impliquant les forces
"Il y a eu non seulement
une collusion, dit-il,
mais la participation
de différents niveaux
de gou
les policiers d'Iguala."
Une soixantaine de
policiers et de militaires
ont aussi été arrêtés.
du 26 au 27 septembre 2014,
43 étudiants d'Ayotzinapa,
dans l'État de Guerrero,
sont arrêtés par la police
avec un groupe criminel.
Ils sont tués, puis brûss
dans une décharge. Les raisons
restent obscures. Seulement
La première enquête officielle
n'attribuait aucuneresponsabili.
Elle concluait qu'un cartel
de narcotrafiquants s'étaitnts.
Cette hypothèse jugée
entachée d'irrégularités
et de zones sombres
a toutefois été rejeilililililis
et experts indépendants.
L'enquête controversée
a repris de zéro après
l'arrivée audududududududududud,
Andrés Obrador, qui promet
de découvrir la vérité.
"Bien sûr, l'affaire
n'est pas close, dit-il,
le b
continuera d'agir."
La mort des autres étudiants
n'a jamais été confirmée,bien qe
ne laisse croire
qu'ils soient toujours en vie.
Ici Danielle Kadjo,
Radio-Canada, Montréa